[موسيقى]
انا سفينه الصحراء جمل جمل وبجسمي ادخر
الماء جمل جمل احتمل الظما وقسوته جمل جمل
دون ما شق دون عناء جمل جمل انا الجمل انا
الجمل جمل هذا خفي يا اطفال يحملني بين
الكسبان بين الكسبان بين مفازات ورمال لا
اشعر اني عتشان لا لا لا لا هذا خفي يا
اطفال يحملني بين الكثبان بين الكثبان بين
مفازات ورمال لا اشعر اني عطشان انا الجمل
انا الجمل جمل جمل انا الجمل انا الجمل
جمل جمل انا الجمل انا الجمل انا الجمل
انا الجمل انا
الجمل اتميز ايضا بسنام وعيون ضخمه ورموش
ضخمه ورموش بهدوء احيا ايامي وبتلك
الصحراء اعيش بتلك الصحراء اتميز ايضا
بسنام وعيون ضخمه ورموش ضخمه ورموش بهدوء
اح احيا ايامي وبتلك الصحراء
اعيش جمل انا سفينه الصحراء جمل جمل
وبجسمي ادخر الماء جمل جمل احتمل الضماء
وقسوته جمل جمل دون ما شق دون عنا جمل جمل
انا الجمل انا الجمل جمل وبيسر امشي واسير
في تلك الاجواء صبور انا جدا صبور وقوي
احمل امتعه اياما امشي وشهور اياما وشهور
وبيسر امشي واسير في تلك الاجواء صبور انا
جدا صبور وقوي احمل امتعه اياما امشي
والشهور انا الجمل انا الجمل جمل جمل انا
الجمل انا الجمل جمل جمل انا الجمل انا
الجمل
انا الجمل انا الجمل انا الجمل
جمل